in Stargate doomed to be woke if Amazon
finally pulled the trigger and give us a
new series
I hope not welcome to psychtrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
for me Star Trek and even Stargate was
always a bit woke I prefer the word
awake it disgusts social commentary it
discussed the problems in our culture it
used the metaphor of Science Fiction to
talk about things like slavery and
racism and sexism but the best sci-fi
the story always comes first but if we
do get a new Stargate series hopefully
something will be announced in the next
couple of months what is then the chance
that Amazon will screw it up and make an
absolutely woke pile of crap well I
think the only way to be fair about this
is to look at some of the projects
Amazon have done over the last couple of
years and have a think about how Brave
they've been in some of their choices
and decide whether we can trust them to
make Stargate remembering it will be
made by MGM but really that's Amazon now
don't forget that if you enjoy the
content you can hit showing button and
become a fully fledged side tracker that
really helps out the channel you can go
to sidestrek.com there's loads of like
merchandise things on there and a load
of new designs coming very soon also if
you are new to the channel don't forget
to like subscribe and hit the Bell
notifications so you miss none of our
new videos as well as the Sidetrack
sides channels the first obvious show I
can think of that is brave and cannot be
described as woke in any way shape or
form is the boys
that show is something I personally love
but it's I love it because it tickles my
stupid bone in the back of my brain the
12 year old that still lurks back there
I do think it's a very clever show it
does actually talk about racism and
sexism and power and our culture a great
deal but it does it in a way that is
kind of ballsy kind of brave and you
know at times pretty much in your face
it has a lot of humor in it it has a lot
of
stupid boy humor as well of things
blowing up and just gross stuff it does
go too far for me at times don't get me
wrong particularly in the last episode
there was a few bits around the orgy
thing that to me just was not
necessarily it went too far but on the
whole it does show that Amazon are
willing to allow stuff to get made that
is
the opposite to Oak a completely
different kind of sci-fi show that
Amazon produced recently is called the
night sky but it was a very slow burn
kind of sci-fi show it had layers to it
again and it was talking about how we
age and talk about culture and our
society but again the story came first
it was a very quite slow pace show 100
not for everyone but again as an example
of Amazon making shows that are a bit
brave are a bit different and making
shows four different demographics which
is not a bad thing now they have messed
it up a few times I'm thinking about
Wheel of Time that is a series that
should have been reasonably easy to make
I generally don't think they put enough
money in it I don't think it was funded
well enough but they 100 made some
massive errors in that show it was
obviously the creators of that show that
are to blame for that not necessarily
Amazon but even that shows shows that
Amazon are willing to try something
different and again be a bit braver one
of the first TV shows Amazon actually
ever produced The Man in the High Castle
was again a very different kind of show
it was the sort of thing that you might
expect to see on Netflix it was based on
a very popular sci-fi novel by Philip K
dick and it was kind of mental to watch
it was based on the premise that Hitler
and the Nazis had won the war with its
friends the Japanese and that they
developed nuclear weapons first now I
actually did really enjoy this series it
kind of fizzled out towards the end but
it was a really good show and again it
was that example of the Amazon can do
sci-fi pretty damn well good Omens was a
TV show that people had tried to make
several times but never been able to do
it but Amazon did
they really got the casting spot on with
this TV series and that's what made it
David Tennant and Michael Sheen were
just both absolutely fantastic this TV
show was based on a Terry Pratchett book
Terry Pratchett is renowned for writing
very popular sci-fi but he's also
renowned for making very popular sci-fi
that's very difficult to put on the
screen but Amazon produced that TV show
and we're going to be lucky enough to
get a second season soon now we're going
to get into what is for me the best
modern Sci-Fi show around at the moment
even though it's currently on Hiatus the
expanse I think the expanse is generally
the most realistic sci-fi it's generally
not loved by everybody it's not not
everyone gets it because it's not like
the glossy sci-fi like Star Trek or even
Stargate really let's remember that it
was Amazon that saved it from Netflix
after Netflix discarded after the second
season it was Amazon that took it on and
continued to make another three seasons
hopefully it will be Amazon that
continue that at some point in the next
12 months okay so let's talk about the
elephant in the room
the rings of power now people have
screamed woke at that they screamed woke
at it six months before they'd seen it
but again we'll let that slide for the
moment
I can understand why some people didn't
enjoy the show I can understand why some
people consider it a bit slow paced
because it was at the first three
episodes were damn right boring but I do
really think it ended on a high I
actually overall really enjoyed the show
I can see why it's cost a billion
dollars to produce so far but I can also
see exactly why it shouldn't have done
for me the rings of power has not been
the success that Amazon were hoping
I think the show is good I enjoyed the
show is it pound for pound a successful
TV show
God no
it's any TV show that costs that much
money really should be extraordinary and
in lots of ways it was but in also lots
of ways it was just boring
I actually think Amazon though will take
on board a lot of the criticism from the
first series and we're already getting
hints from the producers that the second
series will be a little bit different
and will have a much higher pace so that
is another example if true the Amazon
actually does listen to the people that
are important the viewers because let's
have one thing that's very true about
Amazon they do care about the viewers
they do care about the people watching
the TV shows
because they care about money and at the
end of the day the best way to get money
out of us is by making TV shows we want
to watch that's why they make lots of TV
shows for lots of different demographics
because they want subscribers and they
want the cha-ching now you're not going
to like every TV show on any streaming
service particularly not Amazon but does
that mean that they're doomed to make
everything a certain way no Amazon have
shown that over and over again that they
are more than willing and more than
brave enough to make TV shows in lots of
different ways so anybody that says
Stargate new series is doomed to be woke
really isn't thinking it through they
need to go and actually look at some of
the TV shows Amazon produce and then
make a decision so
Stargate might be rubbish when it comes
out it really depends on who they decide
to show run this and how much money they
decide to spend on it
if a lot of the rumors I'm hearing are
true they are willing to really get
behind Stargate and really throw
something good at I'm actually thinking
more and more that we're probably going
to get a Stargate movie soon as soon as
MGM get around to actually hiring a
chief executive in charge of movies
might be one of the reason why we're
still waiting in fact because they don't
have one and then hopefully following
that get a new Stargate franchise
I think Amazon are probably one of the
better companies to do that it's a shame
HBO Max ain't doing it because I think
they are even braver but Amazon are not
wokists look like these are the people
that have The Grand Tour and Clarkson's
farmer he's the least worked person on
the planet this is a streaming service
that is willing to do stuff like that
and don't seem to actually force their
ideals on their creators they seem to
trust the creators to make the shows
they want to make
so again as long as they get the right
person in charge
then I think we're going to get to see a
really great Stargate series but what do
you think get in the comments I at the
end of the day I'm an optimist I will
always be honest with you guys and I
always tell you exactly what I think but
I will also always try to see the silver
lining of every cloud
get in the comments out and tell me if
I'm just being an idiot or whether
you're with me and actually think that
Amazon could do a good job
doesn't mean they will
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
if you enjoy the content please consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fledged side tracker as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]